[Music]
there's a mystery uk man who went viral
after a google maps image showed him
jerking it
on his own bed manifested the
masturbation
and you guys could just react to it
those [ __ ] suckers we've all been in
this position right what is that he's
just laying on his bed jacking off wait
really i can't tell is that his dignity
looks like a girl that's a dude yeah
like because you told me that was
happening like yourself i can't tell
okay look i love the glasses oh my gosh
here you got to get in there he's
looking at you really gotta get you no
he's like this look he's out he's like
this and he's looking at you really i
can't oh
yeah he's like this but i also feel like
because we said it was masturbation i
understand that but if i saw that i
wouldn't
okay
all right that's nice does this have to
do with the opening bell
well it's very abstract because in the
morning you go ding ding ding ding ding
exactly
he's like luna all the time
you don't jack off when luna hits
all-time high what's wrong with you you
should celebrate i jug off using my wife
like a gorilla oh god wait where did the
animal element come in you're one of
those bronx zoo kind of guys
oh you were too [ __ ] up for that video
too you were too [ __ ] up i feel like
you got [ __ ] four eyes right now
sorry
i don't know i don't want to be made fun
of by a dancer that's the worst moment
of my life
how the [ __ ] is this here
it's next up that was the [ __ ]
gorilla i know it's serendipity what the
[ __ ] you know when like an ad video pops
up yeah the [ __ ] gorilla [ __ ]
video but he just right when he said it
i swear that's [ __ ] that's how
they're [ __ ] listening we're
manifesting everything today listen two
things in one video you know okay the
point is okay really though back to this
how the [ __ ] did google maps capture
because you guys know the google car
that drives around taking photos it's
like a 360 camera yeah it's a little bit
like the camera's higher have you guys
ever this is like a photo in the dude's
house i've been behind it dude it takes
forever those guys don't [ __ ] move it
takes [ __ ] forever a picture of me
bent over on google maps really rare
yeah because i was driving it was
driving by uh my mom's house and i was
like fixing the i was trying to put the
hose in
putting the hose in right right that's
what it took how fat is your ass back
then was it pretty fast was it thick and
juicy in there was it like now can you
pull it up on your phone he recognizes
himself by his ass
his pants are around his ankles too you
guys never seen some weird [ __ ] on you
see his whole [ __ ] dude bart's ass
behind my wife is the most thing the
most ass i have on my phone
we've got some chicks on there like a
little [ __ ] that was caught on google
camera oh there's a whole lot dude
there's murderers like all kinds of
there are like one with like i think
it's in like like uh middle of
california and it's like a bunch of like
white ghoul
they changed it that's just irvine oh
they updated humber they updated it boo
because before before right here
i was bent over pulling that hose in how
often do you think they drive around to
update literally searches everything
they can check it's like a really good
amount
they do it enough where i'm always
behind the [ __ ] i'll tell you
that like here's one guy goes 20 miles
an hour two lines of people with eagle
heads standing there
what do you think they did on purpose
wait we got ego heads so some illuminati
meeting or something but it's hard to
tell when the thing's gonna come around
that's scary yeah
wait but that's a street that's an
inside job that's a google inside job
yeah why is that on the street i mean
that's a sidewalk i mean sorry still
does get things like do you think some
other country that are more
pedestrian-like has like google
sidewalk view oh like there's a robot
that goes down the sidewalk and gets all
that yeah like a [ __ ] dumbass with a
gopro on his forehead and you know
getting a man on the street they got a
[ __ ] nerd with one of these just
walking around and [ __ ]
there's one of these dudes being
arrested holy [ __ ] wait is that japan go
back on a couple screw it on the hood
okay yeah like that
that looks like a steve green video kid
i'm holding a gun to a guy's head whoa
what the [ __ ] yeah it's weird stuff
oh horse
naked in the trunk
why is the angle the same oh
are these like um
like do people know what's coming you
know when you're really good get in a
trash can like what you had in your yard
no that was all kind of noodles in my
cameras pointed at you and they
purposely can like
yeah they look at it is it like that
where these guys know it's coming i
think i feel like wild [ __ ] just goes
down all over the world and it's like
right if you're driving around and if
you don't catch it like it's just always
there weird stuff happens all the time
if you're the guy who's driving the
[ __ ] google mouse video you're like
driving down right and you see something
crazy and you're like no no no i got to
back up
double take don't take double take
double right you gotta sure yeah i've
seen um this dude has like a nest cam
right and they say it's like the
craziest street in canada
and then there's like he catches footage
of like dudes throwing down he catches
footage of like a guy like he's on a
bicycle and he just stole a bicycle
right and he's like rolling penny
farthing he stole a bicycle and then a
car just comes down rams that [ __ ]
grabs the bike back and [ __ ] them up
it's like gta [ __ ] whoa you guys know
that but uh that bicycle with the big
[ __ ] wheel and then
yeah yeah yeah little
is that really what it's called
do you know that because you're white
like how do you know that i know because
i did a show called dino yacht club and
i had to learn [ __ ] like that while i
was feeling smart guy i want to ride one
of my favorite
old bicycles do you have a cartoon i
have a cartoon it's called down to the
account yeah this is one of my favorite
google camera things they ever caught it
clearly looks like the google car is
just chasing this poor guy
but look at the slideshow
he's like oh look at that [ __ ] what the
hell guys
he's running why is he running what the
[ __ ] this guy's a weirdo that shipping
container look that guy's funny oh
what the [ __ ] why
that's so randy they're maybe google car
drivers are people too they're maybe it
might be yeah they have to they [ __ ]
afterwards
do you think it was a
human
do they have robots like bot i don't
think they do block cameras yet i don't
think so they will soon i'm sure have
you guys seen those um like little robot
delivery things yeah and homeless people
[ __ ] open them up and jack them are
they you know yeah okay because i've
seen pictures of it i've never seen it
like deliver [ __ ] putting in l.a is a
dumbest idea i know
i've only seen them i've had them in a
hotel before where you ordered like room
service we're gonna open the door like
no way i thought i was gonna be a person
and it's the the [ __ ] r2d2 is this in
vegas you are so rich it's disgusting
dude this is [ __ ] like [ __ ] motel
eight dude
hello master quan i'm so [ __ ] rich
dude yeah did you shot a touchdown
i've always wanted to be like you way to
go dude hey hey
bart dude
[Applause]
house
this is for bart i know what that sounds
like that sounds like bart made a lot of
money off of the facts of hard-working
americans
yeah
so bart and the rest of the one percent
no it's the funniest thing [ __ ] the best
western once in a while like you know a
comment will come around and they say
i don't get it you know bart and joe are
business partners but how come bart is
so [ __ ] rich and joe is so [ __ ]
homeless well first of all i created
this homeless joe narrative and played
into it for a whole damn year no way no
like people what three years
my reality is shifting
joe's like dude it's a narrative
meanwhile he's still living homeless for
like three years let me let's be honest
for a second joe you between you and me
and who cares about the cameras are you
telling me that you are sitting here
telling the cameras like you're taking
l's
because it's funny to you
why wouldn't
we let's be honest you're clearly just
actually taking l's but you can't
[ __ ] admit it except for that you're
in front of the camera oh no it's a it's
actually you know what it is i think
it's one of those things where i have to
mask it because my insecurities are not
allowing me
to really tell the truth i have to play
along with this whole entire oh wait so
joe are you saying you're rich
well i do have a coin here go ahead made
of pure silver
it's a jomalia coin why would he need to
sell it if he's rich why so funny why
would he need to sell that if he's rich
honestly if if even if you hit like 300
million dollars i really truly believe
in my heart that you would live the
exact same i believe that you're a
thousand percent still into camping and
i'm like why
no you probably can't more captains are
cool dude i've turned maybe a dozen
plus people into millionaires this guy's
the biggest waste of my time
because he's the same
what the [ __ ] was the point my little
brother too he's like oh my dream me and
my wife we're gonna do peanut farming
and i'm like peanuts why did i [ __ ] is
he george washington carver or what
i'm like why help you win who gives a
[ __ ]
this biggest waste of my time ever if we
don't know we should ask a 19
millionaire like what do you do with
that money what do you do oh well um i
don't have any of that money actually
because i play the joe narrative right
opposite narrative being a total joke
i'll tell you what i would do 19 million
i'd drive a [ __ ] cement truck on the
freeway and just whatever i want to go
oops and just [ __ ] dump the whole
[ __ ] and then [ __ ] go oh i need help
you are so tyco's father it's disgusting
not exactly because christie
would have said butt like 71 more times
but
you guys better help me before this [ __ ]
[ __ ] dries up into a rock poo poo
kaka derek thank you no but look here's
how stupid this [ __ ] is right
so this guy will sit here and he's
talking about oh yeah i'm a winner big
time but then he's also on camera mostly
talking about how poor and dumb he is
and he's like also sending that to his
editor and saying yeah that looks good
thank you i approve
[Laughter]
but then the stupid [ __ ] who
watch this you're like joe's really poor
he's it's not working out joe is so
[ __ ] stupid and poor
that he's about to go to zero i feel
like it's like
that's the funny part he's amazing hey
guys you guys are not smart and all due
respect i love you half respect for from
steve but you're not smart you mean i
just felt bad for the real like fans
that started getting concerned for me
because i was like
i was like no don't feel bad no no
they're smart though real real concerned
smart don't eat paint it's bad for you
it's actually bad for your brain doesn't
it it's like when you you did the whole
color blinding troll for like one you
had to keep it up your first it's just
so funny to live in it well you told
people you were color blind i told my
wife
yeah like a year
for a year yeah yeah i started dating
and then for me i was just like if this
is the narrative that they want
i'm going to give it's real wait wait
why did you do that huh what was the
motivation i was bored
it was also trending
his dick's black listen to me this guy
told everyone in every edit
i'm a poor [ __ ]
and he's clearly a poor [ __ ] because of
it
that's the best part dude it is he
manifested it and he said he's stacking
[ __ ] dubs all these people eating
paint they'll be like i eat paint yeah
what it's paint nachos what i pour
cheese on top of it it's good
[Music]
you